bueno ambos van a querer conquistar este
8,5 millones de votos o siete por ciento
de sufragios de la llamada tercera vía
los candidatos Ciro Gómez y Simone TV y
los dos van a entrar en contacto
seguramente con ellos para conseguir el
apoyo como en la primera vuelta va a ser
muy importante el voto de las mujeres y
de los evangélicos y de hecho por
sonaron ya ha dicho que balanzarse a por
el voto de las mujeres es posible que
por indicación de su hijo Carlos que es
responsable de su vida online también
recupere temas tradicionales como la
lucha contra el aborto la lucha contra
la legalización de las drogas y la
defensa de la familia tradicional
tiene que conquistar el voto de una
parte de los moderados pero tendrás
sobre todo que desvelar qué quiere hacer
con la economía dejar de hablar de lo
que hizo hace más de 10 años y desvelar
que quiere hacer en el futuro de con
Brasil bueno perdón por la interrupción
y mi segunda pregunta hay temores de
desórdenes si llegara a ganar algún
candidato por el Estrecho margen
pensando por ejemplo en Lula da Silva
Esta es la pregunta del millón no lo
sabremos hasta llegar el momento lo que
sí puede haber es un reconocimiento de
la violencia electoral hemos visto en la
primera vuelta que ha habido ya tres
asesinatos de izquierdistas a manos de
bolsonaristas y varias agresiones Este
es el principal temor cómo va a ser la
campaña si va a ser pacífica y después
después del resultado
todavía hay mucho camino por delante